so the month of June is pet preparedness
month the Red Cross wants families to
remember to include their pets in
whatever emergency plans you may have in
place as well as everyday safety
guidelines now they encourage everyone
to make an emergency kit for your
animals that includes food medicine and
a leash the American Red Cross has
safety and Emergency Equipment for pets
on their website if needed
we recommend having a go bag in every
scenario so having a bag that you can
grab and go but also having one in your
car just in case if an emergency happens
and you're not at home that you have one
in your car ready to go
another rule of thumb is to never leave
your pet inside the car when it's not
running and just a couple of minutes can
be dangerous even deadly for some pets
if it takes long if it's longer than a
few minutes especially in the Las Vegas
Heat